Speaker 1: There is a very interesting new
poll out, a 2024 poll in which Joe Biden is
leading Donald Trump by six.
Now, why do we care about that?
It's September of 2022.
Well, there are a number of different reasons.
One is that like no election, I can remember,
we are already sort of in the 2024 election.
And usually each election is a very kind of
compartmentalized with very clear boundaries
election.
And in this case, it is very different as
much of what is already happening now bears
directly on 2024.
It's also something we care about because
Donald Trump's refrain has been, I'm winning
every poll.
Now, we don't know if Trump is running.
We don't know if Joe Biden is running.
So what it would even mean to lead a poll
is a question, but it is not true that Donald
Trump is leading every poll.
Let's take a look.
The Hill reporting new poll shows Biden with
six point lead on Trump.
Biden is leading Trump by six in a hypothetical
2024 presidential matchup, new polling shows
in a Yahoo News YouGov poll released yesterday,
Wednesday, 48% of registered voters said they'd
vote Biden if the election were today, and
42% say they'd vote Trump.
Now, that's only 90% of the electorate, meaning
there's still another 10% in flux.
That is often the case in these polls.
Biden held a three point lead in the hypothetical
2020 rematch in August from August to September.
Biden's lead has gone from 3 to 6.
Now, again, there are a bunch of different
caveats.
First of all, this is just one poll.
If we look at more polls, you'll see that.
Trump is leading some of them, but more recently,
Biden's leading all of them.
If you look at an Emerson poll from about
two weeks ago, it's Biden plus one.
If you look at a Wall Street Journal poll
from about two and a half weeks ago, it's
Biden plus six.
And then before that, you had Trump leading
three polls in a row, one of which was an
admittedly right leaning Trafalgar Group poll.
So it is not the only poll, this new poll
in which Joe Biden is leading.
But what I want to focus on is the absurdity
of what is going on in the United States.
Trump belongs in prison more than he belongs
on presidential polls.
The idea that Trump might even have a shot
at the Republican nomination.
Is extraordinarily disturbing and embarrassing
for the country.
This is a guy who should never be running
again for anything.
He shouldn't be allowed to run again based
on the things that he that he's done.
And instead, he's in it.
In a hypothetical matchup for the presidency,
and it says way more about the voters than
it does about Donald Trump himself.
And so, as I always say, it's time to start
getting your friends, your family and your
community aware of the fact that they must
vote.
And what better way to warm up to voting in
2024 than voting in 2022?
As I said before, because the concern, of
course, is and this is why I started this
segment by saying in a way that isn't typical,
this election in 2024 are kind of running
together.
The 2024 election is going to be greatly influenced
by what happens now in more ways than one.
Yes, if there is a big maggot running up the
table in November, that emboldens Trump for
2024, and it does build the strength of the
MAGA movement for 2024.
So MAGA people are on the ballot.
If they lose, it's bad for Trump.
If they win, it's good for Trump in 2024.
But there is a much more disgusting way in
which the November election bears directly
on 24, which is there are people who might
win in November who will help Trump steal
the election in 2024.
At the top of the list, of course, is Republican
gubernatorial nominee for Pennsylvania Doug
Mastriano.
Mastriano As I've told you before, and I know
many of you have already heard this Mastriano
was at the January six riot and Mastriano
is a big lie proponent.
And if indeed Mastriano is the governor in
November of 2024 and the Democratic nominee
wins Pennsylvania by a few points, Mastriano
will try to steal Pennsylvania for the Republican
candidate.
He will try.
And I rarely make predictions because there's
so much left to circumstance and possibility
and probability.
Mastriano will try to steal Pennsylvania's
electors in 2024 for the Republican.
If it's a Republican that you know he's in
league with like Trump, and that's why this
is such an important midterm election.
Trump stole nuclear documents, classified
documents, top secret documents to do.
Who the hell knows what with?
And he's polling in the forties.
He's polling in the forties among registered
voters in the United States.
Humiliating.
And the world sees
it now.